[Music]
it's a pretty big fish Serato hollow
point second one today lieutenant you're
gonna want to see this hey guys what's
up hey son of mine dad how's it going
you can't bring a civilian to an active
crime scene
come on son I mean she's not exactly a
civilian I mean look at her
hey doing I'm Tony Caruso you're the
detective that did seven years upstate
was kind of a naughty cop we laugh about
that all the time they don't have to
live with him Anthony your old man said
you're the best detective in the city
I thought of everything I know except
right from wrong that I learned on my
own break one rule they all break you
ever wonder why you're not invited to
more parties I've been watching YouTube
the bantering the t's leads obviously a
deep form of infection that's very
sexual no the cops being killed up there
on the list
the Neptune hotel one of the guests was
shot
we've just posted the autopsy I can't
see it from there right there there's
one thing every good detective knows
what's that it's six o'clock at AU
tomorrow
these cop retreat to a blast Ethics in
modern police work you sign me up to
speak was an easy getting you on that
panel how to slip the organizer a little
doremi you bribe the guy to get me on
the ethics panel cost me 50 bucks you'll
be Pro out because you see what happens
when you play by the rules excuse me Oh
is everything okay it's my father
so no feel my son again
I didn't want to tell you before but
earlier today I disarmed you I can't
wait to tell the guys - oh you're
alright
[Music]
[Music]